hi I'm Erik Demaine and I'm a professor
of computer science here at MIT and I'm
one of three professors in charge of
this class this semester 604 six so I
taught about half of the lectures in the
class
srini taught the other half and Nancy
prepared new problem sets and we all
work together on everything in the class
pretty much we had I think ten TAS says
it and then another five graders so it's
a big teaching infrastructure to deliver
algorithms to 300 students my my entire
career at MIT all have done is taught
different forms of algorithms so 6.46
holds a place particularly dear to my
heart
it's it's a class that's evolved over
time so there's an older version of 604
six on OCW for a when algorithms in the
undergraduate level was all taught in
one semester which was exciting but also
pretty intense and didn't really go into
a lot of depth so several years ago we
split that class into two six double oh
six which is introductory algorithms and
the new six oh four six which is this
class which is intermediate algorithms
beyond what you could implement in an
hour
things that you have to think more about
and prove theorems about so six oh four
six is sort of the more theoretical
counterpart and gets into much more
deeper algorithms and it's exciting and
my whole all of my research is also
around algorithms so this is like this
is me living the dream teaching the
topic that I love and it's exciting
class this is an undergraduate class so
the material is stuff that I should know
really well but every time I teach it I
find that I learn it at an even deeper
level and understand it better also
because I try to add in new topics that
I don't know so well so I learned them
even better and that in turn influences
my research so now I once I understand
the basics really well I can apply them
in new and interesting ways to solve
problems I didn't know how to solve
before algorithms are just so much fun
sometimes I start the class with I'm
Erik Demaine and I love algorithms
it's it's just such a it's it's really
fun material it's it's very creative
it's almost like an art form to come up
with a beautiful algorithm and this
class teaches so many different
algorithms that others have developed
it's kind of like the cream of the crop
there's zillions out there so we can't
cover all of them so we take out
representative examples and find really
cool really interesting or really
beautiful algorithms and it's it's it's
really fun to to cover them all and and
to share that beauty with the students I
think I've taught this class ten times
in some Sun version so it's it's been an
adventure every time is different
and of course the last time is always
the best but next time will be even
better hopefully